it is now five o'clock I've washed my
hands twice sanitized three times and
have maybe teared up about five times it
is just so insane right now my name is
Sakura and I am the CEO of a family-run
Japanese restaurant group in Manhattan
we have 16 different locations with 12
different concepts of Japanese food it's
been four days since the city decided to
shut down all restaurants dining in and
for the past four days I've barely slept
I have a daughter who is 15 months she
just woke me up and I just put her back
to sleep now I am on my computer trying
to log how much my nanny worked I'm a
single mom and because I've been working
a lot through this coronavirus crisis my
nanny has been very essential so that's
what I'm doing at 4:30 3:00 in the
morning as well as trying to get ready
for the day it's been very very crazy
four days I know it's very different
from what a lot of people are
experiencing right now I just want to
show you what my day looks like trying
to create our online infrastructure for
example high powers we do not do takeout
and to suddenly have to close our doors
means we have to set up something to
support that kind of business things are
just changing every single day and so we
as a company we're also changing every
single day I'm hoping that today we'll
see an uptick in online orders I'm just
keeping my fingers crossed all right
guys it's almost 529 I need to get some
sleep before I rush off to the office
tomorrow to tackle on another
it's 8:20 and I've pressed news ample
enough times so it's time for me to get
up take my temperature 97.3 so we're all
set and now it's time to get ready done
picking out clothes for my daughter in
order to keep my family safe in order to
see my daughter I have to put on the
mask wash my hands and then say hi to
her and I try not to hug her or kiss her
just it's it's hard not to
you know hugs it's that's probably one
of the hardest parts even just patting
her head makes me feel better society
must stop they try to maximize my time
with her in the morning sight nanny I
told her not to come into the city
anymore because I also don't want to get
her sick luckily my mom is watching her
I'm trying to enjoy these little moments
with my daughter
it's 10:14 and I am leaving my apartment
after having a very heated discussion
about what to do with each restaurant
it's you know a family business and it's
very difficult when you're talking about
closing businesses that have been part
of the family so to talk about what were
we going to do how are we going to take
care of the staff it is a very difficult
conversation and had to say goodbye to
my daughter who you know screaming and
crying and says mama it's just hard to
take now I'm going to bike to work I am
on 10th Street now making
my first stops places that are open make
sure everyone is doing okay only take
out a try right Ken while I was that
high caller we had a few neighbors stop
by and say how can I help with buying a
coffee help you guys we said yes yes of
course even a little bit helps for your
local places so this is my office
it's 1134 and so far what we've done is
set up so that our graphic team can
clock in and clock out remotely we've
talked about finalizing the phone number
so that any employees who have questions
about unemployment and things like that
have one central phone number at 2:30 I
got a call from my boss telling us that
he has made the decision to close all of
the locations and and then how much
we'll need to sustain the business feel
better with omar epps this is my
ultimate comfort food it makes me feel
like a kid that's happy
[Music]
we don't get any more locations this is
what it looks like now I've been working
on these New York Warren paperwork just
so that we are in legal compliance with
letting the state as well as our
employees know about our southern
closures it is now five o'clock I've
washed my hands twice sanitized three
times and have maybe teared up about
five times I think that's the right
decision but I rarely wish that it was
communicated better or if we had more of
a plan in place this is the reality of
what our situation is like from just a
legal standpoint from an operational
standpoint from an emotional standpoint
it's just insane now our conference room
has become a vegetable shop as well as
things like homemade mayonnaise we have
still so much stuff and so we're asking
the employees who are choosing to come
in to pick up their checks to bring a
bag so that they can take home some
stuff I'm a psycho girl East Village
picking up
I'm going to package them for delivery
it's six o'clock in Soho and look how
empty the streets are it's just always
so wonderful to see friends especially
friends in the industry nice just still
put a smile on my face so now what I'm
doing is getting the reports ready to
close out everything bring that to the
office tomorrow morning I'm not gonna be
serving my friends who come and eat here
and that's really sad for us in the
hospitality industry because that's why
we're in it seeing the customers excited
to be here and it's really the industry
where you need social interactions and
to physically be together especially in
New York City where we don't have any
space restaurants are where we come
together with friends with lovers with
co-workers with family
and to
not be witness to all those celebrations
and gatherings and not be a place for
that that's what this virus has done to
us I don't know when but in some shape
or form people will be back hopefully we
will be back and we're going to
celebrate you know be together again I'm
locking up the door for psycho garage
village just making my rounds to make
sure that all of our places are closed
tomorrow I'll be coming back and making
sure anything that can be turned off
will be turned off completely so we
don't waste any unnecessary energy and
also money
bye-bye money son yo Sam bye-bye
I'm walking home I'm just excited to get
home wash my hands take a shower and see
my sleeping baby my parents
here nice and clean I've washed my hands
used alcohol to wipe my hands and my
phone my mask scan 96.9 I'm okay to go
next door I finally put my daughter to
sleep put the laundry in the machine and
having a minute to kind of reflect on
the day it's just hard to kind of wrap
my mind around everything and I don't
think anyone can I just am at a loss of
knowing how to support the people who
make our business run but what I can do
is try to come up with several plans to
put into place when things change but
maybe closing will give us a peace of
mind to exactly know that our staff is
healthy and I'll get to spend more time
with my daughter I've probably seen my
daughter maybe a total of three hours in
the past four days so I'm looking
forward to spending time with her and my
job still continues before I sign off I
want to say thank you for your support I
truly hope that I and my staff will be
able to welcome you back to our
restaurants whether that's in two weeks
or a month or months
I hope to see you again soon
good night
[Music]
you
[Music]